on today's episode we're talking about
Resident Evil's remakes and Veronicas
during an interview with noisy pixel
Resident Evil producer yoshiaki
hirobayashi confirmed that Capcom
currently has no plans to remake
Resident Evil Code Veronica if you're
new to the Resident Evil games code
Veronica is a cult classic that was
first released as a Dreamcast exclusive
but eventually came to the PlayStation 2
with more cutscenes the game is set
between Resident Evil 2 and 3 games that
had remakes released in 2019 and 2020
respectively so it's only natural to
wonder if Capcom plans to redo this
middle story as well luckily for fans
that lack of plans doesn't seem to be
set in stone in hirobayashi added that
the opportunity for a cold Veronica
remake hadn't been ruled out entirely in
the meantime if you find yourself
needing to play the game on current gen
Hardware you can check out the 2011
remaster on Xbox series xns via backward
compatibility and while that resonate
Evil game won't be getting a remake yet
one of the most beloved entry is in the
series Resident Evil 4 will be getting a
massive overhaul next year launching on
March 24th and a new trailer showed off
more of the game's big set piece moments
and creepy monsters during capcom's
latest showcase you can also see some of
the new mechanics and features coming in
the remake during the trailer for
example now there's a dedicated button
for trying to stealth your way through
the environment as well as a Parry
mechanic to deflect melee attacks when
you're being swarmed there is currently
an re4 remake Hands-On preview on our
Channel right now in which Kurt indovina
walks you through his time with the game
this could be the resident 4 remake fans
want but not the one they're expecting
to get and this can all be illustrated
by a single choice that Capcom made with
a dog and if you know the dog you know
the dog you know what dog in other
Resident Evil news a demo of Resident
Evil Villages third person mode is now
available on Steam PlayStation 4
PlayStation 5 Xbox One and Xbox series X
NS you can play the demo for a total of
60 minutes if you exit the demo before
the 60 minutes are up you can resume
where you left off you can finish the
demo ahead of the 60 Minute limit in
which case you can restart it and play
for the remaining time however if you
played the last version of the demo from
May 1st 2021 to May 9th 2021 the 60
Minute Timer continues from that
previous iteration so if you played it
for the full 60 Minutes you will be
unable to play this new version how
weird is that you know what else is
weird it's Friday it doesn't really feel
like it but it's it's Friday so let me
know what you're playing this weekend
and make sure you go and check out that
Hands-On preview Link in the description
see you next week